hi guys i have i have a sad truth to
inform you of uh
i think joe biden is a russian agent
that's right at the very least an asset
of the russian government or a useful
idiot for the russians
sound familiar so we got the story from
becker news
stunned silence overseas after joe
biden's bizarre reaction to killer putin
question
joe biden is proving to be the laughing
stock of the nato summit although the
embarrassing development is no laughing
matter
cnn's chief national affairs
correspondent jeff zeleny asked biden a
question
about vladimir putin in brussels uh
biden's response was odd to say the
least quote
in a weekend interview vladimir putin
laughed at the suggestion that you
called him a killer
is that still your belief sir that he's
a killer quote
and i will continue to continue the
trend of asking a second question he
continued
do you believe that if he does agree to
cooperate then what kind of challenge do
you find yourself
in how would you ever trust him if
ronald reagan said trust but verify
what do you say to vladimir putin zeleny
asked
this was biden's rambling response
answer the first question i'm laughing
too he said in awkward science they
actually i
well look he has made clear that uh uh
the answer is i believe that he has in
the past
essentially acknowledged that he was uh
there's certain things that he would or
did do but look
when i was asked a question on the air i
answered honestly but it's not much of a
i don't think it matters a lot in terms
okay you get the point
so so i'm not i'm not being serious when
i say he's a russian agent yeah i'm just
making fun of the democrats
but what about uh what what about joe
biden shuts down keystone pipeline and
then he approves
the the ukraine pipeline he's giving
russia
pipeline access while shutting down
american pipelines and
especially the time whitmer in michigan
wanted to shut down another oil pipeline
the colonial pipeline gets shut down
what do these people work for it's
almost like it's amazing because
i don't know if you guys have probably
heard the democrats project that's what
they do
they'll do something and then accuse
republicans of doing it all they do is
project
were they literally projecting the
russian asset thing were they literally
agents of russia
saying like well don't look at us it's
trump he works for russia meanwhile
they're the ones working for russia
i think it's highly probable i mean i
mean not literally no but i mean it's
it's genuinely possible i like i i think
that there's
if it's not russia it's china i don't
think that our politicians are owned by
us
anymore that's my personal opinion i
know it's it's wonky conspiracy theory
stuff but
um i don't see much behavior on their on
their part that
demonstrates affinity or allegiance to
this nation that's just my personal
opinion well i agree but i don't think
it's
like they're owned by somebody else's
necessarily some probably are i mean
sualwell was was hooking up with uh with
fung fung or whatever
it's fung fung okay get your
pronunciations right you bigot okay
anyway the point is
uh now i forgot what i was gonna say
because uh
what were we talking about oh yeah yeah
yeah positive being owned fang fang i
started thinking about like what was he
doing with that lady
yeah you know what he was really you
don't want to know i just want to see
the video don't know well
dianne feinstein right said that that
driver who was inspired whatever the
point is
it's not that they're necessarily owned
by other people it's that they're they
have no allegiance to us
their allegiance is to extract value
from the system walk away
pad their bank accounts these are here's
what you need to understand about
congress
these are mediocre people at best and
that's being generous
who found a way to get rich and stamp
their name in the history books
they've done nothing of real merit other
than convince people to vote for them
or to put money behind their name so
other people see them on tv
then they become famous by virtue of
winning an election many of them
disappear
some of them never become prominent
enough but their name is in the history
book
they get they get they get that salary
for a little bit some of them get rich
off of it
look at aoc she's got an infinity pool
she got a tesla
man she's she's doing really well from a
bartender ain't it her abuela's not
doing so hot but you know
no i think her whale is doing really
well apparently she said something like
they did get the money from trump oh
they did
something like that i don't know i i i
saw an article that said
that apparently puerto rico her family
did get the aid okay
and so she came out and spoke out
against aoc which was a
a huge admission and and really should
be talked about more because
aoc was trying to of course exploit her
her
poor grandmother and and it backfired
so tremendously to the fact where she
had to deny donations to her
poor grandmother i mean if if you're at
a political
point in your life or you have to say no
no no don't give my poor
downtrodden grandmother yeah don't give
my abuelita
some money i mean that's that's when you
know you're messing up but but
we actually do have the story though uh
aoc's aunt says blame puerto rico not
trump for a boiling misery
puerto rico received hurricane relief
funding but it hasn't reached all the
people who need help
an aunt of new york congresswoman claims
according to a report so she's
she's exploiting her family i'm not here
to rehash like some stupid aoc thing but
it's a really good example of
she is the she is the epitome of i'm the
working class i was a bartender and the
conservatives hate me for being a
bartender because they're elitists and
i'm here fighting for you
and uh parking my tesla illegally when i
go shop for some organic produce in my
luxury
apartment in dc within the infinity pool
and look at my poor abuelita she needs
your help and then turns out
it's actually not trump's fault at all
because they did get there
that is exploiting and extracting value
from the system but hey hey
i'm not here to single out aoc i can
point the finger at each and every one
of these republicans
who do literally nothing but sit on
their hands
and there was a lot of corruption in
puerto rico especially after
a lot of money was sent from mainline
united states to
help with the hurricane relief there and
a lot of
a lot of the puerto rican government
officials some of them kept that money
for themselves a lot of them even locked
up
huge important resources in warehouses
for themselves so there was a huge
corruption that was ultimately
pointed directly at donald trump and the
mainstream media said look donald
trump's responsible for puerto rico
meanwhile you know a lot of puerto rican
politicians got caught with
stealing a lot of the aid and they may
or like steal something
i forgot the exact story but i remember
seeing warehouses of of water bottles
that were absolutely huge and then it
never made it to
to people who'd never had running water
um and and that wasn't
donald trump who did that i remember
when trump was was throwing like paper
towels to people
like it was a sporting event yes and
they're like what a scumbag and i'm like
he's so cavalier yeah i literally just
didn't understand why who cared
yeah and i'm not even i'm not even a
donald trump fan i never was a fan of
his i always criticized him
but but still when the mainstream media
is so ridiculously just trying to blame
everything on him whether it's puerto
rico whether it's the hurricane whether
it's the ebola abuela or whatever
grandmother
or or you know whatever the mainstream
media is against i have to look into and
investigate because
you usually see something that is not
what the mainstream media says it is and
they were foaming at the mouth going
crazy for russia for a very long time
and they were wrong
when it came to the russian collusion
story that started it all when donald
trump came in and russia was
was used as the boogeyman as the main
chief enemy of the united states and all
the information that came out
eventually proved that it was all wrong
it was all basically so why
do why do believe any believe anything
they say about anything i don't
i i because the weather man's right
sometimes so it gives credibility to the
to the stupid news so but no i mean like
we we still
i got fox news and yahoo and the
independent pulled up and we take we
take these articles at their word
even though we know a good portion of
the time it's bonk
to be fair i actually go through these
articles for the most part and trying
like
you know i pulled up becker news for
instance and this is this is a
it's not newsguard certified or anything
but there's literally a tweet video of
of
joe biden doing this so that's something
i can actually verify
to a certain degree maybe the video is
edited i have no idea
but most of these these news outlets you
know they come out they talk about china
and one of the big fears i have
especially we were talking to we're
talking cassandra fairbanks about war
what if they're just lying again they
lied about about iraq and the middle
east and wmds
so what if they're just lying again i
think i think it's a healthy development
honestly that
so many people have woken up to this
reality that there is nothing
trustworthy out there i mean
you tune into tim pool to find out the
truth more often than you do cnn and
that's the truth i mean most most people
will
rely on our smaller outlets to try and
get some semblance of
object objectivity to be fair though cnn
gets hundreds of millions of views
they're propped up by youtube
youtube will put them on the front page
and we get downrank d ranked we get
hidden we get shadowband
people say oh i don't get notifications
for your show anymore yeah that's right
so you know what man you guys if you're
listening you go to tempest.com become a
member
you share this show right now you take
the url right now you put it on facebook
twitter or whatever
because there's no way for us to beat a
rigged game unless everybody stands up
and and does something look i'm not
saying this is the best show in the
world and i'm always right
but if you at least think we deserve
more ratings than cnn share the show
yep i'll uh i'll pop on youtube and i'll
see a video frequently too and it'll say
like
the fouchy interview like it's the big
one it'll be some random youtuber i've
never heard of
500 000 views wow like it is just shoved
to the
to the front that's what they want if
you if you're one of these
these are the grifters of youtube not
all of them some of them are just like
you know dopey pop culture youtubers but
when they get their news from from
fake media lying press all that stuff
just just
fake news they believe it and then
youtube says hey we'll put you on the
front page if you interview fouchy
vouching they go cool and they don't
know
anything it's really remarkable to me
how angry so many people are on twitter
when they clearly have no idea what
they're talking about and of course
there's the left grifters who will play
semantic games
then there are these run-of-the-mill
like regular lefties who just
never read a news article one day they
stumble across a piece of news where
it's like
something weird happens like that's
strange what's happening and then they
believe
all the lies they believe all the lies
then when people try and introduce them
to a show like this they'll say i don't
know man that sounds like fake news the
media told me brian stelter
he was like don't watch that youtube he
said not to so i'm not gonna
don't read the wikileaks it's illegal as
cnn was telling us before a few years
ago when the
wikileaks hillary clinton emails were
coming out actually showing us a totally
different perspective
of the reality of who hillary clinton
really was to who she was presented as
in the mainstream media
you look at how bill gates is presented
dr fauci is presented it's like they're
lord and saviors it's like they're
the scientists when bill gates is not a
medical doctor
or a scientist which which needs to be
reiterated and
and you know truly one of the most
important things that
i believe we should do and i've been
trying to do
on my own independent you know youtube
channel is to try to make people
critically think
is to try to make people understand that
you shouldn't believe anyone
unless you do your own research unless
you do your own homework and you get
to see different perspectives and then
make up your own mind on them
you're right but a lot of people just
want to be in the tribe they just
look man look when youtube says hey
we're going to put you on
you want a million subscribers you want
to be a big famous youtuber with the
gold medal
hey we'll do that for you just agree
with dr fauci no matter what he says and
interview him
then the emails come out now what we get
after the emails come out which show
yeah he was lying for sure questioning
whether or not his own
uh the nih funding was contributing to
this that was actually
it was actually suspected that may have
been the case and then publicly said no
it's not true it's a lie
it's not it's not real no it's it's the
lab leak isn't true and
his own scientist that he was consulting
with believed it was possible yeah i'm
not saying it was like
fauci behind the scenes laughing and
mocking people talking about how smart
he was and how he was manipulating
everybody
but behind the scenes he very much was
holding his private positions
and then publicly giving different
positions yeah and if if
if not for rand paul we probably don't
even know about this i mean that we
would have known about the emails but we
wouldn't have had him on the record
just prior to that release where he
denies it all i thought it was profound
and
and you know this is these these are the
types of things that
all of us were privy to because we do
our own research but but as you were
saying people need to be more critical
and and i wish they were but the truth
is you can only lead people to water
most don't want to drink
and you know i i just think you have to
you have to find your own tribe
i just got a one one quick caveat i was
just very very critical of congress
rand paul gets a pass thank you he's not
perfect but i always he's he's pretty
good he's better than most
yeah him and messi so you guys are
telling me that cnn and buzzfeed when
they said that the fouchy emails only
showed how hard you work wasn't true
that was amazing so they leak all these
emails or they get they foil them
freedom of information
and then buzzfeed's like leaked emails
show how how fauci was fighting hard to
keep america stable
it's just like us oh jeez frank frank
honesty is that what it said yeah a
refreshing source of pressure
and then when fauci comes out later he's
like if they're criticizing me
they're criticizing science oh yeah i'm
sorry he didn't really say i am science
i am undebunkable how did you flip the
table over yeah he didn't really do that
they're gonna call me fake news they're
gonna be like false did [ __ ] you
tim light on the show snopes he did say
the first part though if you criticize
me you're criticizing science
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8 p.m where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you